NARRATOR: As a new day begins
on Oak Island, Rick Lagina,
along with his nephew Peter
Fornetti, Craig Tester,
and other members of their
team, gather at the Oak
Island Visitor's Center.
- Hi, are you Brennan?
- I'm Brennan.
Craig Tester.
Nice to meet you,
Craig, finally.
Nice to meet you.
NARRATOR: They have scheduled
a meeting with representatives
of Choice Drilling, a company
that specializes in a process
known as sonic drilling.
So that's the rig?
This is the rig.
NARRATOR: Unlike regular air
or mud rotary drilling, which
uses powerful drill
bits to literally grind
beneath the ground,
sonic drilling uses
vibrations to create a high
frequency sound which can
literally pulverize obstacles.
A coring barrel is
then used to extract
samples of earth and
objects from areas
as much as 500 feet deep.
I think we all are quite
curious how this rig works.
We've never seen one before.
Should be a treat for you.
Well, we've got some
real targets for you.
We'll see.
Well, I'm eager
for the challenge.
Well, it is Oak Island.
It is.
CRAIG TESTER: Let's head on
back so you guys can set up.
All right.
Sounds good.
Good luck.
I've always been
against just guessing.
I mean, the whole point
of the seismic program
was to find anomalous features
underground in the Money Pit.
Well, they targeted an area
that's worth investigating.
And thus we're going
to drill there.
If you can't get excited about
that, it's time to go home.
NARRATOR: Assisting the team
with their drilling operation
is area geologist
Terry Matheson.
OK, so the surveyors put
in the D line, D2 to D6.
So there's our spot.
So it's halfway between
D and E, right on line 6.
So DE6.
DE6 it is.
NARRATOR: Using last year's
geotech grid as a reference,
the team has decided
to dig their first hole
at a location known as DE6.
Here, they hope to find not only
a possible system of tunnels
some 100 feet deep, but
also a 30-foot wide chamber
at a depth of
approximately 170 feet.
Well, there it goes.
Is it through?
Yeah, it went through fast.
Excellent.
Well, who knows what this is?
All right.
Take the bit right over.
Oh!
Bring it on over.
Here it comes.
That's, uh, 83--
or 93.
Sorry.
93.
Wow.
That's interesting.
And that's the way it's cut.
I love it.
It was laying this way.
Yeah.
Not standing up.
It was laying like this.
So it could be the
top of a tunnel.
Wow.
NARRATOR: Wood from a tunnel?
But from what period?
Could it be little more than the
remains of a searcher tunnel,
one of the dozens
that have been dug
on the island over the years?
Or could it be physical evidence
from an original underground
structure, one that may have
been put there centuries ago
by the people who came
to the island looking
to hide an incredible treasure?
Yeah, man.
Hey, guys.
Hi.
Wow.
Look what we got.
This is what we
came into at 93 feet.
We came right out
of the material
into a horizontal beam.
So it sure looks
like it's a tunnel.
We've encountered
what we believe
to be a tunnel in an area
where we have our target
based on the seismic data.
But we don't know
what that means.
It could be original work.
We don't know.
And that's what we're
trying to decipher.
It's exciting.
It can't be just a coincidence.
Definitely get
this carbon dated.
If it comes back
really, really old, then
we know it's original people.
Exactly.
Yeah.
NARRATOR: The discovery of
a possible tunnel directly
connected to the
Money Pit offers
exciting news for the Laginas
and members of their team.
It means that the seismic data
they received from Eagle Canada
was able to accurately
pinpoint the existence
of a structure located
some 93 feet below ground.
It also means that as they
continue to drill down deeper,
the team may also be successful
at finding another critically
important chamber, the one
which they believe might contain
the legendary Chappel vault.
Is this interesting?
Absolutely.
You know, it mandates
that we continue.
And we're going to
continue the process
and get down to the where
the anomaly is featured.
Yeah.
Exactly.